سانتقل الى صور مباشره من روما حيث حطت
طائره اجلاء كانت تقل على متنها مواطنين
ودبلوماسيين ورسميين كانوا موجودين في
السودان طبعا هذه الطائره حطت هناك بعدما
تم اجلاء هؤلاء من العاصمه الخرطوم الى
ميناء بورتسودان ومنها طبعا الى روما
للتذكير مشاهدينا دول اوروبيه عده قامت
باجلاء مواطنيها اجلاء جوي فرنسا بريطانيا
ايطاليا وايضا عدد اخر من الدول الاوروبيه
اجلت مواطنيها بعمليات اجلاء جويه من
السودان الى مسقط راسه وبعض هؤلاء ايضا
كان قد وصل الى مطار جده ومن هناك تم
اجلائهم ايضا الى دولهم
اذا مسؤولين رسميين ايطاليين او وفد يعني
موجودين هناك لاستقبال هذه الطائره
واستقبال المواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم من
السودان بعد التطورات الاخيره والاشتباكات
التي حصلت
عمليه الاجلاء هذه يعني
ايضا كان هناك بموازاتها عمليات اجلاء
دوليه لجميع الرعايه ومعظم الرعايه
الموجودين داخل السودان المرحله الاولى
التي نتحدث عنها هنا هي مرحله اجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والرسميه والعاملين
في السفارات وفي المنظمات الدوليه
والامميه طبعا هناك مرحله ثانيه هي مرحله
اجلاء المواطنين التي بدات من قبل الجانب
المصري وبدات ايضا من قبل الدول العربيه
ان كان المملكه العربيه السعوديه وقطر
كويت كل الجاليات العربيه التي موجوده
كانت يعني موجوده داخل الخرطوم
اذا هبطت الطائره كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
ووصلت الى مطار روما وهي
تقل رعايه تم اجلائهم من السودان
[موسيقى]
عمليات الاجلاء هذه تم اتخاذ القرار بها
بعد بعدما تعرضت يعني عدد من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه من المقر الرسميه لعمليه قصف
عشوائيه تبادل الطرفين الجيش الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع التهم فيها ايضا
تتزامن مع رفض واستحاله يعني حتى الساعه
ان يكون هناك مسار سلمي ومسار
لانهاء هذا الصراع والاشتباك الدائر بين
الطرفين
والمستمر حتى الساعه في داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم وفي مناطق في الاطراف
اذا الطائره العسكريه الايطاليه حطت في
مطار روما
ونتابع مشاهدينا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات